(audience cheering)
- All hour, we've celebrated
just how valuable friends
are to our happiness.
So let's close out with
one last feel-good story
about friendship.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat theme music)
Sometimes you make a friend
without exactly realizing it at the time.
That's what happened to an
Indiana man named Canyon,
when he discovered he
had a mouse in his house.
Here he is explaining it on TikTok.
- So there's a mouse in my house
and I can't kill the mouse.
So I got one of these
little like humane catchers
where you can then like
let them back outside,
like away from your home.
Okay, so I just came home
from my lunch at work
and I caught one.
But the problem is,
is that I can't like just drop,
it's freezing outside right now.
So instead I gave him his own little,
like this huge cooking pot.
And then inside of it,
please don't jump out.
I gave him like, he's gonna jump out.
I gave him like a banana and paper towels.
And in case he wants to like
live in there for a minute.
Do I have a pet mouse now?
(audience clapping and cheering)
- I think they might need air.
Of course, the story of
this budding friendship
didn't end there.
So let's get Canyon on the line right now
to tell us if he gave the mouse air.
(audience cheering and clapping)
So what's up?
So you really, look, first
of all, we are the same.
I cannot kill things.
Like I do not wanna kill something.
I try and take it outside.
My friends laugh at me,
but you did, however,
put a lid on something and
maybe there was no air.
- Yeah.
- The big concern was
that there was no air
although it's a very light lid
and that mouse could have easily
jumped out if it wanted to.
So I was thankful that
it did not jump out.
Everyone was concerned
with how much air it had,
but I was, I couldn't help but look at it.
I was constantly lifting the lid.
He was, he did a great job.
(Kelly laughs)
- My God, I love you.
So Canyon posted the video
of him releasing Julian
back into the wild.
So let's see it.
- Okay. This is where
you go live your life.
Oh, hi little guy.
Go on, go live free.
Wait here, wait.
He's running.
He's so cute.
Here.
If you want, there's snacks,
there's snacks and stuff in here.
I left snacks.
There's snacks, there's a banana.
I love you, have a
blessed and fruitful life.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- So, how do you think
the mouse is doing now?
Have you seen the mouse?
- I, you know, I have gone
and checked on him many times
but I think he's out living his best life.
He's either a bachelor or
he's got kids to take care of
but I have visited him plenty of times
and he has not been home.
So the house is still there
but I think he's just out, you
know, he's out on the town.
I mean, I left him more than
any mouse could ever want
so I'm sure he's just
(Kelly laughs)
living his best life for sure.
- Oh my God, I love you Canyon.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I'm liking your post right now.
(message tone dings)
That's not all though.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson show,
wanna honor ultimate
over-achievers, just like you, sir.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars
to help out other mice.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Thank you so much, thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- That's wonderful.
(audience cheering)